in this web security course you will
learn all about devsec ops from me beau
carnes you will learn how to take
advantage of common web vulnerabilities
how to fix those vulnerabilities and how
to use devsecops tools to make sure your
applications are secure toward the end
eric smalling from sneak will talk about
securing containers and more about
devsec ops
soon i'll be showing you how to
implement common hacking techniques but
first i'll give an overview of devsecops
devsecops refers to the integration of
security practices into a devops
software delivery model in a devsecops
model security objectives are integrated
as early as possible in the life cycle
of software development and security
considerations are important throughout
the life cycle
later i'll be going into more details
about what this actually means in
practice but first to really understand
devsec ops it can be helpful to first
understand devops and also
vulnerabilities thanks to sneak for
sponsoring this course
their resources made this possible
let's start with vulnerabilities
the whole point of security is to
protect against vulnerabilities so let's
understand the different types and
afterwards i'll discuss devops
the average cost of a data breach in
2020 was
3.86 million dollars
and global cyber crime costs are
expected to reach 6 trillion dollars by
the end of this year it is estimated
that 90 of web applications are
vulnerable to hacking
and 68 of those are vulnerable to the
breach of sensitive data
in 2020 there were over
000 data breaches in the united states
according to the identity theft resource
center and over
155.8 million individuals were affected
by data exposures when thinking about
security it is important to understand
the difference between a vulnerability
an exploit and a threat a security
vulnerability is a software code flaw or
a system misconfiguration
that hackers can use to gain
unauthorized access to a system or
network
once inside the attackers can leverage
authorizations and privileges to
compromise systems and assets
and exploit is the method hackers use to
exploit a vulnerability
an exploit is typically a piece of
custom software or a sequence of
commands there are even exploit kits
that can be embedded in compromised web
pages where they continuously scan for
vulnerabilities
as soon as a weakness is detected the
kit immediately attempts to deploy and
exploit such as injecting malware into
the host system a threat is the actual
or hypothetical event in which one or
more exploits use a vulnerability to
mount and attack only a small amount of
known vulnerabilities will be used to
hack into a system vulnerabilities that
pose the highest risk are those that
have a higher chance of being exploited
and therefore should be the ones that
are prioritized
security vulnerabilities can be found in
all different areas related to software
here are some common security
vulnerabilities in applications and
websites
there are two different important lists
of weaknesses in web applications
the first list is created by the open
web application security project or
owasp they have a popular list called
the owasp top 10 that features the most
commonly exploited vulnerabilities the
second list is cwe or common weakness
enumeration which is a community
developed list of common software and
hardware weakness types that have
security ramifications
this list is run by the mitre or miter
corporation which is a not-for-profit
company that operates federal
government-funded r d centers
they create the cwe 25 which is their
list of the 25 most dangerous software
weaknesses
in the cwe 25 there are three major
types of application and website
security weaknesses there's porous
defenses risky resource management and
insecure interaction between components
a porous defense's weakness is one that
could allow users to bypass or spoof
authentication and authorization
processes
authentication verifies the identity of
someone trying to access a system while
authorization is the set of access and
usage permissions assigned to the user
porous defense weakness examples include
weak password encoding
insufficiently protected credentials
missing or single factor authentication
insecurely inherited permissions or
sessions that don't expire in a timely
manner all of these porous defense
vulnerability types can allow hackers to
successfully access sensitive resources
exploits that leverage these
vulnerabilities may include credential
stuffing attacks
hijacking of session ids stealing login
credentials or man-in-the-middle attacks
the next vulnerable category is risky
management of resources such as memory
functions and open source frameworks
the types of vulnerabilities in this
category are out of bound reader write
which is the same as buffer overflow
the application can be tricked into
writing or reading data past the end or
before the beginning of the intended
memory buffer
also path traversal this allows
attackers to get to path names that let
them access files out of restricted
directories
i'll be showing an example of this later
exploiting these vulnerabilities allow
hackers to gain control over an
application or damage files or even
access sensitive information and then
the final major weakness area is
insecure interaction between components
many applications today send and receive
data across a wide range of services
threads and processes
the way different components interact
with with each other can introduce
vulnerabilities
weaknesses that expose a web application
or website in this manner can include
cross-site scripting this is when user
inputs are not handled securely it can
open up the possibility for cross-site
scripting attacks that enable attackers
to inject client-side scripts into web
pages viewed by other users
this is a very common vulnerability
there's also cross-site request forgery
this is improper verification of whether
a seemingly legitimate and authentic
request was intentionally sent
these attacks are often mounted via
social engineering vectors such as bogus
emails that trick a user to click a link
which then sends a forged request to a
site or server where the user has
already been authenticated if apps and
websites don't properly implement
security controls for interaction
between components
this leaves them vulnerable to back door
attacks scripting attacks worms trojan
horses and other exploits that deploy
malicious code to wreak havoc on
infrastructure data and systems
between the os 10 and cwe 25 lists it is
clear that broken access control is the
top vulnerability
94 percent of applications have some
sort of broken access control
access control makes sure that users
cannot act outside of their intended
permissions so if this is not set up
properly it can lead to unauthorized
information disclosure or modification
or even destruction of data now let's
talk about devops which is an important
part of devsecops
devops is a concept that has been talked
about and written about for a long time
and many definitions of devops have
emerged
devops is basically a set of practices
that combine software development the
dev and it operations the ops
it aims to shorten the system's
development life cycle and provides
continuous delivery with high software
availability
as you can see in the devops pipeline it
basically goes on infinitely going
through all these different steps
most modern devops organizations will
depend on some combination of continuous
integration and continuous deployment or
delivery systems in the form of a ci cd
pipeline
as part of the life cycle a variety of
automated security testing and
validation can be performed without
requiring the manual work of a human
operator
and this is all part of the software
development lifecycle
here's an example of a common devops
flow
first a developer will write code and
push it to a repo at that point the cicd
pipeline starts
there are automated tests then a version
is built that's eventually deployed to
production
there are tests at every step to assure
code quality
but in this model security is sometimes
only considered right before deploying
to production
devsecops follows a similar flow but
adds automated security considerations
throughout the process
security is integrated with the devops
devsecops codifies security objectives
as part of the overall goal structure
the shield represents all the places we
test for security
different tools are used for different
steps i'll talk some about the specific
tools later
defsec ops should be thought of as the
natural continuation of devops rather
than as a separate idea or concept
activities designed to identify and
ideally solve security issues are
injected early in the life cycle of
application development rather than
after a product is released
this is accomplished by enabling
development teams to perform many of the
security tasks independently within the
software development lifecycle
to integrate security objectives early
in the development of an application
start before the first line of code is
ever written
security can integrate and begin
effective threat modeling during the
initial concept of the system
application or even the individual user
story a static analysis linters and
policy engines can be run anytime a
developer checks in code ensuring that
any low-hanging fruit is dealt with
before the changes move further upstream
later i'll be showing you how to use a
tool to check code for security issues
while you're writing it software
composition analysis can be applied to
confirm that any open source
dependencies have compatible licenses
and are free of vulnerabilities
i'll be showing you how to use a tool to
check software dependencies for security
issues it can be very helpful to get
immediate feedback on the relative
security of the code you've written
and this helps individual developers
take ownership of security issues
once code is checked in static
application security testing or sas
tools can be used to identify
vulnerabilities and perform software
composition analysis
sas tools should be integrated into post
commit processes to ensure that new code
introduced is proactively scanned for
vulnerabilities
having a sas tool integration in place
enables remediation of vulnerabilities
early in the software development life
cycle
and it reduces application risk and
exposure
after the code builds you can start to
employ security integration tests
running the code in an isolated
container sandbox allows for automated
testing of things like network calls
input validation and authorization
these tests are often part of dynamic
application scanning tools or dast
these tests generate fast feedback
enabling quick iteration and triage of
any issues that are identified causing
minimal disruption to the overall stream
if things like unexplained network calls
or unsanitized input occur the tests
fail and the pipeline generates
actionable feedback in the form of
reporting and notifications to the
relevant teams
next things like correct logging and
access controls can be tested
does the application log relevant
security and performance metrics
correctly
is access limited to the correct subset
of individuals or even prevented
entirely
finally the application makes its way to
production
but security tests continue automated
patching and configuration management
ensure the production environment is
always running the latest and most
secure versions of software dependencies
special techniques and tools can be used
to secure containers
later you will learn how to do this in a
real world environment
using a devsecops or cicd pipeline helps
integrate security objectives at each
phase
allowing the rapid delivery to be
maintained
the entire approach helps minimize
vulnerabilities that reach production
thereby reducing the cost associated
with fixing security flaws
defsec ops aims to build security into
every stage of the delivery process and
establish a plan for security automation
when thinking about security you should
remember that your code is just the tip
of the iceberg
in an average software project only 10
to 20 percent of code is custom code yes
it is important to make sure your custom
code is secure
but there's a lot more to think about
eighty to ninety percent of mini code
bases consist of open source code
modules and libraries
the frameworks and libraries that you
import can themselves import more
frameworks and libraries
this is code that you didn't actually
write yourself you know on average
eighty percent of vulnerabilities are
found in direct dependencies it doesn't
matter how good you are at writing
secure code if you import vulnerable
dependencies then there are containers
these often consist of hundreds of linux
packages inherited from public sources
again code that you didn't actually
write yourself and you can't forget
about infrastructure as code
this opens up a bunch of new attack
vectors for malicious actors
misconfiguration is the number one cloud
vulnerability
devsecops properly implemented should
cover all of these areas
so it should be becoming obvious but
let's talk more about why devsec ops
practices are important
as companies get larger there's often
more software cloud technologies and
devops methodologies
more software means more of the
organization's risk becomes digital
making it increasingly challenging to
secure digital assets
cloud technologies means that many of
the it and infrastructure risks are
moved to the cloud this raises the
importance of permission and access
management since everything can be
accessed from anywhere as you've seen
devstech ops brings security into devops
enabling development teams to secure
what they build at their pace while also
creating greater collaboration between
development and security practitioners
security teams offer expertise and
tooling to increase developer autonomy
while still providing a level of
oversight so here are six benefits of
the devsecop model
compared to the traditional devops model
faster delivery
the speed of software delivery is
improved when security is integrated in
the pipeline
bugs are identified and fixed before
deployment allowing developers to focus
on shipping features
improved security posture
security is a feature from the design
phase onwards
a shared responsibility model ensures
security is tightly integrated from
building deploying to securing
production workloads
reduced costs
identifying vulnerabilities and bugs
before deploying results in an
exponential reduction in risk and
operational costs
enhancing the value of devops
improving overall security posture as a
culture of shared responsibility is
created by the integration of security
practices into devops
improving security integration and pace
cost and time of secure software
delivery is reduced through eliminating
the need to retrofit security controls
post development
enabling greater overall business
success greater trust in the security of
develop software and embracing new
technologies enables enhanced revenue
growth and expanded business offerings
it's about to get practical i'm going to
show you how to exploit some common web
app vulnerabilities and i'm going to
show you how to use devsecops tools to
make sure your software is secure we're
going to learn some hacking techniques
as well as learn how to prevent hacking
by using this goof app
this was developed by sneak and it's a
vulnerable demo app it was created with
some common vulnerabilities so we can
learn how to
hack those vulnerabilities and also even
better how to fix those vulnerabilities
so the whole goal is to
make sure the apps that you develop do
not have vulnerabilities but we can also
use it to figure out how to check for
check vulnerabilities and other programs
and apps
so let's download this we're going to
i'm going to
copy this
now i've got my terminal open
and i'm just going to clone that project
so git clone and then i'll paste in the
link here
so after you clone it there's two ways
to get this running
you can run [ __ ] on your local machine
like this and then we already cloned it
then you can do npm install and npm
start there is actually a simpler way to
do it i think which is to use docker
compose you can use either method i'm
going to use docker compose so to
install docker compose you can follow
the instructions on this website for
whatever your operating system is i'm
going to install it on mac
okay i'm just going to copy this or you
can just remember this docker compose up
build
now you can see i'm in the directory
node.js goof
and then we'll do docker
compose
up
build
okay this looks like it's running let's
check it on our web browser i'm going to
open up a new tab
and it loads
the goof to do app
this is just a simple app it's not
really full featured or anything
but it has enough as part of it that we
can test some hacking techniques and
then we'll also be able to see how to
fix those and how to secure our app so
it can't be hacked so let's just do some
tests uh to do let's see
buy milk
finish
tutorial
eat
ice
cream
okay well this to do app looks pretty
good before we start hacking it i'm
going to actually open up the code for
the app so we can look at the code and
we'll be going kind of going back and
forth between the actual code used to
develop this app and the way that we can
hack the app and then we'll go back to
the code and see how we can fix the
things that are vulnerable
okay so just open up the the node.js
goof directory in any code editor i'm
using vs code
and if we go into views we can see
that's using the ejs extension
and then here's the view we're on right
now
where you can create a new item and it's
going to return each of the to-do's here
but you can see there are a few other
views here we have an admin view
account
and then we have index layout so we are
going to start our hacking
by trying to get into this admin page
so if i go here and do slash login
we want to figure out how we can log
into this admin access
so a hacker will possibly do some sort
of social engineering or some or maybe
just searching on websites to find out
what the admin username is it could be
admin or in this case it's admin
at sneak
dot io
because this was developed by sneak.io
so there's a few ways we could try to
figure out how to get into this page
but using a a different tool than just
the web browser is going to be helpful
we could use our command line and use
curl
or we can do it in a more kind of visual
way and use something called burp suite
burp suite is is a tool that a lot of
penetration testers and hackers use and
burp suite has a lot of features that
make it easy to test different things
about websites and change things and
really try to hack different parts of
websites
so i'm just going to type in download
burps into google and i'm going to
download the free community edition for
my operating system
okay just open up burp suite for the
first time and i'm just gonna click next
to create a temporary project and start
burp
and what we want to do is be able to
intercept the http request that we're
sending to the website and change them
we want to modify the requests that are
going to the websites and we can do that
by going to the target no going to the
proxy tab
intercept
and now we have intercept is on
but to actually intercept the things we
need to intercept the things on a web
browser
it's kind of complicated to set it up to
use our built-in web browsers like
google chrome or firefox but burp suite
has an embedded browser that makes it a
lot simpler so we're going to open up
this embedded browser
and here's the burp suite embedded
browser and i'm going to make sure
intercept is off for now
when it's on you're going to have to
click forward in between each request
but we will do that later but not quite
yet
now i'm just going to get the url
localhost 3001
and then i'll paste it into the browser
okay great we can see the website right
in the burp suite browser now i'm going
to go over to slash login
okay so
where now they're at this page i'm going
to turn intercept on
and i'll move this over to the side here
and so we'll use the username we already
know which is admin
at sneak
dot io
and then i'll just put anything for the
password and then click submit
if we go over here it hasn't actually
even though i click submit it hasn't
tried to submit it yet
it it's gonna it caught this request it
intercepted the request right here
so you can see it has the username it
also has the password i was trying to
type wrong but i spelled it wrong
and
we can now change what's sent to the
backend we can change what values are
sent to the back end so at this point
if i just click forward it's just going
to send that those values now i already
said that this wasn't a fully complete
app so when you log in incorrect it
doesn't currently have a page that shows
you when you log in and correct it just
says this so we know we've logged in
incorrectly if we've logged if we logged
into admin correctly it would actually
go to the admin page but we're going to
go back to the login page
and turn intercept off
and then i'm going to type that in one
more time and i'm just going to type in
a password one more time i'm going to
turn intercept on
we're going to attempt a nosql injection
now what a hacker would do would be just
to try a bunch of different methods
and eventually they're going to try a
nosql injection so this is the method
i'm going to show you here now so if we
go over here to our request
right now the password is a string we're
all passing in strings but what if the
password wasn't a string what if it was
an object could an object actually be
harmful or considered an issue well
let's try if we're going to be sitting
in a json object we're going to actually
have to change this request a bit
we're going instead of accepting text
this is now going to be a json object so
we're gonna change it to
application
slash
json
star slash sorry q equals 0.5 that's how
we're going to accept json objects
and then we're also going to change the
content type so where is that so this is
going to become application
json
now we can just pass in instead of this
text down here we're going to pass in an
object and the object is going to have
the username and password
username is going to be the same thing
as before but this time we have to put
in strings because this is an object so
this is going to be admin at sneak
dot io
and then we'll have the password
but remember we're doing a no sql
injection we're not going to pass the
string here this is going to be an
object
and the object is going to go like this
let me just type it all in really quick
this here
in this nosql injection it's passed in
as is to the password property and it
has a specific meaning to mongodb
it uses this dollar sign gt operation
which stands for greater than so we in
essence tell mongodb to match that
username with any record that has a
password that is greater than
this empty string
which is bound to hit a record so this
is a nosql injection vector so let's try
this i'm going to forward this on
and then we'll forward it one more time
and now you can see
we are now
in the admin act admin access granted
we're now logged in as admin we're going
to do a few more of these and then we're
going to go into the code and see how to
fix some of these problems
so there's another
url on this page once you're logged in
called account
details
so since we're logged in we can get to
the account details page
oh and let me turn on intercept or turn
off intercept so it goes to a quicker so
we can enter these account details
i'm just about to show you a code
injection
this is rendered as a handlebars view
let's see if you uh if we go back over
to this code so this is a this is
creating handlebars
and the same view is used for both the
get request which shows the account
details as well as the form itself for a
post request which updates the account
details
so it's uh it's basically server side
rendering
so the way the form works is that it
receives the profile information
and then passes it as is to the template
this means however that the attacker is
able to control a variable that flows
directly from the request into the view
template library now a hacker isn't
going to know all this but they're going
to try a bunch of things to figure out
if it just happens to maybe have one of
these vulnerabilities
so if you just do it like normal we
could just type in everything
and it's going to to save the account
details to the database so to do this
code injection instead of using burp
suite i'm going to show you how to do
with curl okay i'm just going to paste
in this line here this is going to use
curl to log into the website using the
administrator account we have the
administrator and now we actually are
using the real password super secret
password uh you could also use some of
these other method other method we
showed before to try to hack in without
knowing the password but in this case
i'm showing you a different
vulnerability so we're just going to use
the real password just don't tell
anybody what it is
and we are going to save this cookie to
c dot txt that way that we can do
another curl command and still be logged
in with this administrator cookie so
let me just hit enter here okay so we're
logged in to the administrator it says
we're redirecting to slash admin because
it logged in correctly
now i'm just going to paste in another
curl command so you can see the end of
this curl command is the url we're going
to which is the account details page
this is the one we were just looking at
on the web browser
we are doing a post request we're not
trying to get the the file we're not
trying to get the page we're trying to
send data to the page and we're going to
log in
using the c.txt file this was stored on
the computer when we logged in with the
administrator here so we're still the
administrator when we do this action
and if you see here this is the
information that's being sent over
so you can see we have fields for every
field on that page we have email first
name last name country phone
so those are all these details on here
but you can see there's one final thing
there's layout
if we pass layout
when we pass it to a template language
like handlebars this could lead to a
local file inclusion or path traversal
vulnerability so let me show you what
happens
you can see we do layout and then we
have we pass in the file path to get to
a file on the server
so we're going to see if we can actually
get information from the server and yes
it's it's returning
the package.json file
so you could use the same concept to
try to return the text of any file on
the server this could include passwords
hash passwords or any sort of ins any
sort of data you may be able to figure
out by using this this hack
now let's look at another vulnerability
we're going to see this one first right
in the code and then we'll go and try it
out in the browser
so i'm on the admin view and if we go
down
we could see that it introduces a
redirect page query path
the redirect page is rendered as raw
html and not properly escaped because it
uses this dash instead of it should be
an equal sign so this introduces a
cross-site scripting vulnerability let
me show you how you would take advantage
of this vulnerability
okay so i'm going to go to the normal
login page and now i'm going to add a
query parameter
it's going to be redirect page
but instead of adding a normal url or
page that we're going to i'm going to
add some javascript
and it works this alert came up
so we've been able to successfully
inject javascript code into this page
okay i'm going to show off one more
vulnerability and then we'll start
looking into how we can find and fix
these vulnerabilities so i'm at the main
to-do here and i'm just going to try
some different things like let's see if
we can add markdown
hello
now that i see i can add markdown but
maybe there's something else i can do
now
there's different libraries that can be
used to add markdown like this in this
case we're using the marked library and
a hacker may know that certain libraries
have certain vulnerabilities
but even if they don't know about
certain vulnerabilities they may just
try a bunch of different things and see
what they can figure out so let's see if
we can make a link appear
okay we can make it show a link right
here
in this case i was supposed to put http
colon slash flash but you can see it
still works here
and
now let's see if we can get it to run
javascript
[Music]
well that's good it's not vulnerable to
just typing in javascript in there
there may be something else we could try
though
let's see if we can make another link
and just put in some javascript right in
here
okay that didn't work which is good
but one thing that is common is to
represent data in a different way so so
i got the same one we just typed in but
i'm going to make a few slight changes
we can actually replace this colon with
the html entity for a colon
so it's going to be like
this
and then this final
parenthesis we can represent with the
html entity
so let's test this
well it didn't run the javascript but
you can see something different happened
it doesn't look the same as this so we
now know that the sanitation is
happening
in a different way when we we put these
other symbols here
and like i said this is using the open
source library markdown so anybody can
just run just read through that code and
they may be able to figure out
vulnerabilities just by reading through
the code so the reason why this isn't
working is because the people who
created marked are actually sanitizing
this out and looking for something like
this and removing it
however we can actually take advantage
of something that a browser does a
browser actually tries to fix your
javascript code so if it sees something
wrong it actually tries to figure out
and figure out what you meant so we can
type something like this like the actual
word this here
and the browser is just going to try to
try to try to figure out what this means
but the
interesting thing is the marked library
when it's trying to sanitize things it's
not trying it's not looking for
this set of characters it's only looking
for just this set of characters so if it
sees this full set of characters
it's not going to sanitize it's not
going to replace it with anything but
the browser will still be able to try to
figure out what this means so let's just
put this in
here and now we have a link here if i
click the link
now it's running the javascript code
so we're able to send javascript code
that can run right in someone's browser
and
in this to do app this could be
something that other people to view the
to do's and you could actually make
someone run javascript code so this is
the cross-site scripting vulnerability
right in our application just because of
this library that we're using so let's
see if we can go about finding and
fixing some of these vulnerabilities
let's go back into our code editor
there's a program called sneak code
which is a static application security
testing software or sas
and there are plug-ins for a lot of
different ides there's a vs code plug-in
that we're going to use right now so
let's install this plug-in this is going
to help us
find our security vulnerabilities and
fix our security vulnerabilities
so i'm just gonna search for sneak
and i'll just install this once sneak
vulnerability scanner with the twelve
thousand here
okay now that this is installed
we can see a new icon here the sneak
icon
and it's going to work better
we're going to actually connect it here
okay so i got my account created and i'm
logged in and i can authenticate
so we're already searching the open
source vulnerabilities up here
and then down here code securing quality
we're gonna have to enable it so click
this link
and then enable
and then save changes
okay let me go back over here
and now it's just it's analyzing the
code from this project
this analysis runs automatically
whenever you open a folder or a
workplace
and then also when you save it's going
to scan the code automatically
so we can start clicking into these so
these are our open source dependencies
things that were different packages we
have and then down here is the
vulnerabilities in our actual custom
code so i'm going to click one of these
issues here
and you can see it can it's going to go
right here it's going to underline it
it's going to tell you what the the
error is
and then it's going to give you some
more information about it so actually
let's let's look at this issue in
particular
so this is for the login
unsanitized input from the ac request
body flows and defined where it is using
an sql query this may result in a sql
injection vulnerability
and this was one of the vulnerabilities
that we were able to take advantage of
so we now know where the vulnerability
is and it's going to over here give us
some information about how to fix it
so it's showing here it's showing some
it says this vulnerability was fixed by
255 projects here are three example
fixes this is similar code from other
projects showing what people did to fix
this mistake
so if we go we can actually go through
these to get different examples of what
people did
so we also can get more information
about the vulnerability by clicking here
more info and we can see it's the the
sql injection vulnerability
so here with the login handler it's
actually going to take whatever password
the user entered and then
it's going to this user.find is going to
pass that everything directly to the
backend database for validation
and it's going to
pass the exact text that the user
entered or in our case remember this is
where we passed an object we were able
to pass an object with the with greater
than and this allowed us to log into the
administrator account without knowing
the password just by passing in an
object
and because this is just passing in
whatever the user types in into the
database that's how we were able to do
this sql injection
and it's all because mongodb uses json
to query the database so it's the sql
injection or in this case actually a
nosql injection
so the very absolute simplest way to
solve this problem would just be to cast
this to a string
the password
so if someone puts in an object it will
actually when it gets cast to a string
it will look like this
if you cast an object to a string it
just looks
like
object
object
which would not would which would not be
the correct password
there are this is like a simplest way
but there there's much better ways such
as there's different libraries that can
help you
and there's different ways that you can
can make sure this is not a problem but
this was just like the simplest way to
make sure someone cannot pass an object
in for the password so
we'll just ignore that even though there
are better ways to fix that we're going
to ignore that because we're going to
use this um this way to fix this problem
not only can you see all your code
security issues by just clicking here if
we actually go to our file explorer any
file that's read is actually going to be
a file that sneak has found to have
security issues so we can close that
and we can see
that it's finding security issues in
this file and these are all things if i
click on here
and then view problem
it's going to show right in here avoid
hard-coding values that are meant to be
secret find a hard-coding hard code
string used in the express
session
so we're actually the secret is right in
here you don't want to put a secret
right in here you want to use an
environment variable if we go here we
can click on quick fix and then to show
you the suggestion so
here are some examples of how people
fixed it
this person didn't they changed this the
secret to
just a variable that hasn't been defined
yet really you want to use a
like i said an environment variable to
fix a problem like this
so we can actually go through each of
these issues
in the code security here
and then
change them one at a time so here's one
we just talked about about the hard
coding and we have another the secret
token is right in here
so that's how sneak is going to help us
fix our issues so let's see what this
one is well disable x powered by header
for your express app because it exposes
information about the the used framework
to potential attackers and then it tells
you what to use consider using helmet
middleware some of the vulnerabilities
that we were able to exploit
wasn't even in the code that was written
for this app
it was in the open source dependencies
so let's go to this open source security
section and one thing i didn't mention
is that these are color coded so
if it's in red that means it's basically
one of the worst possible things that
could happen you know and then orange is
bad but not quite as bad and
the yellow is the mildest or i guess
gray would be the mildest so anything
that's red you definitely want to fix
one of the issues that we exploited was
in handlebars so if we fix the handle if
we click handlebars
it's showing that we're using handlebars
4.0.14
and it's suggesting to fix this issue we
can
upgrade to
4.1.0
and then it's going to go on to
show us exactly what the problem
that's happened that happened so the
problem related to prototype pollution
and then the unsafe object recursive
merge
so once i know about this handler things
there's a plenty of things i can do to
just kind of
upgrade handlebars
so one thing is that i can go right into
my packs.json
and you see we still have it here
hbs
now i can actually just
change this to
four point
one
point zero like is recommended and if i
just close some of these here
you can see that it's showing right in
our package.json file it's showing all
of these different vulnerabilities and
if i click here
show the most severe vulnerability
now it's saying
for jquery i should upgrade to 3.5.0
so i can just type in
3.5.0 to upgrade that
and then we can go through every single
one of these and just try to find just
try to find all what what's vulnerable
but some things we may not want to
upgrade but some things we may want to
upgrade just depending on the severity
of the vulnerability and how it's going
to impact your app
another way you can go about doing this
is using the command line
so i'll just open up a new terminal down
here
and
i don't have sneak installed quite yet
you just do npm install
sneak
at latest
so this i do if you have npm
and now i can just run
sneak test
oh yeah first i have to authenticate
sneak sneak
off
okay i've authenticated so before we
authenticated for vs code now we're
authenticating for the command line
and then sneak test
and this is going to find
all this these things and it's going to
so you can find it right in vs code or
we can just use the command line
and see all the red things are the high
severity so this is kind of nice to to
find out all the high severity issues
and these are basically all dependencies
and it's showing what we need to go
through so you'd want to go through and
especially all the high severity things
you want to go through and you want to
upgrade to the the version that's not
going to have these issues
and then there's also sneak
code test
so before it was showing all the things
on our dependencies
and now it's showing all the problems in
our actual custom code this part of this
project so that's just the same so the
first command would be stuff from this
open source security panel up here and
the second command we run was from this
code security panel here
so and we can see that there's three
really important issues that we should
try to make sure we fix
another cool way to kind of find
vulnerabilities is just through the web
interface so let's go to the sneak
website
i'm going to go to my dashboard
and it's showing that we can run sneak
monitor here
right in our here so if i do sneak
monitor
and it's showing a website we can go to
i'm going to copy that copy that
okay now we're in here we can actually
see
all these same issues but now it's
actually easier to get more information
so this is one of the our dependencies
we have
and we can show more detail it's going
to show how we fix that and then we can
also actually get more information like
cwe29
this is a path traversal issue which is
one of the things we exploited if you
can remember if you remember
so we could actually fix that issue
just by upgrading to
4.11 instead of 4.7
and then if we want we can also get more
information about the library
and it goes right to the npm website for
the library
so we go down here and you can see all
the things that are definitely need to
get fixed
so with the high priority critical
priority
and so marked
oh yeah i saw mark yet so this is
another this is one that we exploited
and if we just upgrade to marked 0.3.18
then the one where we were typing in to
do items and we were able to get
javascript into there if we upgrade this
then that won't be a problem
we can also go here where
it's
suggesting very specific fixes
so
def is saying definitely upgrade these
things and it's going to fix all these
different issues
and then if we go here this is just
going to show
all of our dependencies
and you can see if we click into here
body parser is a dependency and inside
body departure there's another
dependency this qs here and if we click
into qs well this has a high severity
issue
so that's something we definitely want
to know about
so this is pretty great it's a way to
figure out all the security issues and
all the dependencies on your on your uh
on your app applications
there's no way to be able to know all
these on your own you pretty much need a
tool like this to make sure your your
application isn't using these these
dependencies that have different
vulnerabilities like this
now this is outside the scope of this
course but there's also a way to set up
on sneak so anytime you push your code
to repository it's automatically going
to run all these tests
and before you even merge a poll request
it will show all the security issues
that could be in
the the poll request that you're trying
to do and then you can be required to
fix them before you actually merge that
pull request
but now we're going to talk about
containers
eric smalling is going to teach the next
part of this course about securing
containers he has a ton of experience in
this area and is great at explaining
everything he'll also give another quick
overview of devsecops
hey everybody eric here i am here to
talk to you about containers and
security and all the things that we have
to look at now that
we're containerizing our applications
a little bit about myself so you know
where i'm coming from i am a software
developer for the past 30 years give or
take uh i am a senior developer advocate
now at sneak a
software uh security scanning company
and um the last decade or so my career
really been spent more around the ci cd
build automation tests kind of a
world and um
during that i i discovered docker docker
i've been using docker since about 2013
uh back in the early early days before
that we had any orchestrators or even
compose or anything
today i am docker captain and i'm
certified in all three of the kubernetes
certifications it
means anything to you and uh you can get
a hold of me on at that twitter address
or linkedin or whatever all the socials
so what are we going to talk about today
first of all we're going to get into how
does security
play with devops is it is it a a versus
kind of a thing or do they work together
uh next we'll get into what are the
challenges we face specifically uh as
developers uh making uh putting our apps
in containers and i'm gonna get into a
demonstration to show you what can
happen
if you don't uh look out for these kind
of problems and we'll get into this you
know how can you be proactive to avoid
the the situations you'll see in that
demonstration and finally we'll wrap it
all up at the end
so devops is an interesting term it's um
i mean literally it is just a
a melding of development and operations
and everything else in between
uh to cooperate to work together and to
automate things together um and to work
well together um unfortunately it's
turned into kind of a buzzword in our
field and it's kind of gone the way
agile did for a while there where
consultants will sell you agile they'll
also sell you devops or you'll have a
devops team or devops tools but really
it's more about the concept of making
sure
we're all working together towards
fast um uh repeatable builds and um
uh
making sure that everything you know is
done well together as a team
and often devops is uh visualized with
our software delivery life cycle
pipelines the pipeline was kind of
popularized back when the continuous
delivery book was written and um this is
a simplistic pipeline i'm showing here
uh yours may look more complicated than
that but
generally you look at ideation to
production from left to right and it's
like an assembly line
in this diagram i put our company's
little patch logo on a couple of the
blocks where we historically have seen
security applied to our pipelines in
production first of all
i mean that's time table sticks we've
always had some kind of security being
applied to production whether it be
firewalling or
role-based access control
trip wires all the things that you think
of when you think of hardening for
production we've had security around
that well
we also started as the security inter in
when we started doing pipelines and
started doing continuous delivery we saw
it applied as a stage a security audits
would happen
and usually they'd be a late stage in
that pipeline because often times it was
a manual process and it was like a
gating kind of a thing where some team
would go in and look at your application
and determine whether or not you have
increased your vulnerabilities or or in
some in some way made things less secure
and they would pull the cord stop the
line and you'd have to go in and figure
out what it was and usually this was
after functional testing so it was like
a late bug and you now you got to put
your mind back into the state of what
was i doing when we worked on that code
because we've moved forward since then
um
or it could have been automated there
were automated tools that have been
around for a while but usually they were
so slow
um or their licensing was so onerous
that you could only run a few copies of
it or you could only run it on certain
hardware that your ci pipeline would use
and um
so again these would be late stage
things that cause you to have to stop
and
figure out what happened and hopefully
get a fix in quick for the release or
unfortunately often it would be put on
the backlog for a new release you know
coming down the line and you go to
production with known vulnerabilities
which is never good
as containers started to come in and we
modernized the the way
we did security against those you saw
scanning coming in at the registry level
so you'd push an image to a image
registry
and
it might have a built-in scanning
functionality and uh it would grind away
for however long it took and it would
come back often with just a big list of
here's all the cves have fun with that
hopefully um you also had similar things
that were able to be done similar kind
of scanning in your ci
as your repo change so as code is merged
into the main line or whatever branching
strategy you used uh something would
kick off do your builds and one of the
automated tests that would happen would
be that
security scan so you'd build the image
you might be able to scan it or send it
off to something to scan it even before
it gets to the registry that's kind of
cool because now you can break the build
without having to rely on some kind of
call back from the registry to you know
break the pipeline after it's already
been going
so
that same kind of tool if it's fast
enough could actually be applied
pre-merge so if you're doing git for
instance you have pull requests often
where you have a short little branch and
you come back into your main or master
or whatever you're using and um you
could have one of the automated tests
that happens as part of the validation
of that pull request be a security scan
again now the tool needs to be fast
enough to do that because otherwise
people aren't going to want to wait a
day
for a pull request to get reviewed they
want to get it in and be iterative and
get it done but the holy grail of this
is really to get that kind of
scanning capability to be so fast and so
uh useful that a developer will use it
day in and day out on their workstation
um
you want it not only to be fast but you
want the output of it to be actionable
so that the developer can be proactive
and not having security and that team be
an adversarial relationship you want to
be able to say hey
issues have come up here's the
information i have and i can act on this
information or i can at least go to the
security folks and talk to them
intelligently about what i'm seeing and
get you know cooperation there instead
of an adversarial role and this is where
we get the term devsecops now devsecops
in my opinion really isn't a thing it is
more of a reminder that between dev and
ops
security needs to be part of that
thing security needs to be invited to
our little devops party right they need
to be
just
integrated if you will now
i've talked about container you know
that they're challenging what is it
that's challenging about containers
well for developers
you we are increasing our scope of
responsibility sometimes greatly this is
an area where
historically you know we've dealt with
securing our code and maybe the
libraries we pull in but
containers are adding operating system
level things things like what base image
are you using what is it bringing along
what distribution is that base image
built on what packages are you
installing on top of it how are you
installing your application what file
system permissions are using what user
id are you using all of that kind of
stuff
which we've known about as developers
but we might not have really dealt with
it much because the teams
that uh deployed our software or or
built the systems that we deployed to
dealt with it um and so we we have a bit
of a lack of expertise around how do you
harden the linux and ubuntu versus
ascentos
uh file system um distribution
these are things that other people did
for us before now hopefully we're
working with those teams as we build our
docker files in kubernetes yaml and
everything else so that
we're crafting these files correctly but
i need to know as a developer if i need
to tweak that file then i'm doing it
right and i don't want to have to open a
ticket every time i want to change a
docker file
to my ops team to say hey let's work
together to fix this i mean if it's
something complicated sure but if i'm
just changing you know what package i
need for something
there's got to be a better way
and on top of all of this any security
practice you add to a developer's day to
day can't impact their velocity
business has
bought into and given us the ability to
do these iterative cd pipelines all is
because it's all about velocity getting
from ideation to market in front of the
customer as fast as you can we're not
going to we don't want to introduce
something that's going to slow that down
in fact they'd probably
really like us to faster if we can
okay so let's go back to talking about
what developers know about containers
now we know our applications you know
when we
write them that we have to pay attention
to
the the code itself the code has to be
clean you can't be introducing in sql
injection and issues or whatever we've
got to write secure code and we know
also that our libraries need to be clean
as well um but what's new is these
docker files like i talked about
we're dealing with
operating system issues now and for
instance looking at this little
screenshot i know what python is because
maybe i'm a python programmer and i know
that version three of python is what i'm
on but do i know what minor version this
is do i know what linux distribution
it's on top of do i need to know what
about the packages i'm installing and am
i doing it correctly or am i installing
them um in in a way that's putting
things on the file system that doesn't
need to be there
all sorts of questions like that come up
and of course we've got infrastructure
as code files like terraform or cloud
formation um
and uh the big grand daddy of them all
would be kubernetes and this is
you know
if you're in
orchestrated container land you're
dealing with kubernetes most likely
nowadays and this is an api that changes
every three three times a year and has a
lot of knobs and switches on it and it's
very easy to make a mistake and um
caused problem that you didn't even know
you were making this mistake
it's enough to get your app running on
these
various technologies to make you
hyperventilate but uh
uh hardening the app for security on top
of that well that that's that's that's
asking even more
okay so that's enough talking slides and
hypotheticals let's actually look at a
demonstration of this in action
so let me start the scene let's say
we're at a company we have a java
enterprise application that we've had
running for years and years it's it's
our big money maker
but it's in a kind of maintenance phase
we're not doing active developments um
or anything just bug fixes here and
there and so a couple years ago when it
was time to
you know when containers came on the
scene and and uh
we got access to kubernetes servers we
decided hey we want to do that we want
to take advantage of containers and the
the standardized packaging and
deployment mechanisms we get with the
with the orchestrator
so we lifted and shifted our java tomcat
application into a container we've been
running it that way ever since so if you
look at this docker file this is a
multi-stage docker file which means that
there are multiple different from lines
and for each one of those that's a stage
so here we have two of them we have the
initial one which builds our application
that's uh based on the uh official maven
image from docker and the maven folks
and uh then we have a second one that is
the official tomcat image from apache
topka
and anyone who's done tomcat for a while
and this is november of 2021 right now
and this is still eight five twenty one
that's a pretty old version
um but the attitude for a lot of folks
is if it ain't broke don't fix it this
is the version we were at in production
when we containerized and we're sticking
to it because we it works and we're not
making changes that need anything new
but look at we'll come back to that
decision in a second
the rest of the file is pretty basic
it's just set up a couple configuration
files and then copy artifacts from the
build
stage into the main stage so the final
image we produce is tomcat plus our
application and a couple good things so
let's take a look at this running uh
this is the top level sample servlet
that you see right here and you can see
i pulled this up so you can see that
8521 is definitely the version we're
running um just to make sure our app is
running i'll pull that up and there it
is there's our beautiful to-do list
makes billions of dollars for us or so i
say
um but honestly the the our app is not
what i want to talk about today there
may be problems in it but that's not the
discussion let me switch hats now and
put on my black hat hacker hat now i may
be
looking for vulnerable servers to
exploit as a hacker
and in doing that i'll do my studies and
i'll see you know i may be looking at
tomcats release notes for
vulnerabilities they've fixed and you
can see there's a bunch of
fixes they've done and throughout here
we're seeing all sorts of things there's
denial of service attacks there's um
oh gosh incorrectly documented cj all
sorts of stuff but the one that's
interesting to me are these remote code
execution ones
this means that if i'm able to exploit
something that has one of these
vulnerabilities in it i might be able to
run my own code and somebody else's
server pretty bad
this one we're looking at right now is
uh fixed in 8523 that tells me that
anyone on 85 22 or older
might be vulnerable
and as you saw that that company is
running 8521.
so i could dig into this if i go into
the vulnerability database this is
sneaks vulnerability database databases
very similar to miter we add a few extra
you know pieces of information to it uh
but what's i could dig into this and i
could find out what is it about tomcat
util that has issues and what what is it
there are the issues and try to craft
something but i'm in this for speed and
i almost want to find something quick
and i see that there's a couple of
exploit db links i'm going to click on
one
and what this is is code this happens to
be python code
that
i'm not a huge python coder but i could
read this and i could tell oh this has
got two methods it's a proof of concept
script that will check for
and
exploit against that cve uh to prove
whether or not you have it or whether
you're patched so i'm gonna copy that
and i have a couple of let me set this
up i forgot to do this before the call
so i'm going to run this
uh
shell script this is going to
basically it's going to take that python
script it's going to wrap it in the
container and aliase it for me so it's
easy to run for this demonstration and
i'm out and that's done
and
i'm going to run the check side of that
and you can imagine this would be
automated if i was really going after a
bunch of servers i might have a ton of
ips and ports that i'm ping ping ping
ping kind of like the old war games war
dialer going through looking for
vulnerable and i found one that's my
local ip i'm just running this locally
on a docker kubernetes
docker desktop kubernetes
uh this works any combinations i want to
run it on or any docker executable um
this is saying it's vulnerable and it's
stuck a poc jsp onto the server so let's
jump back over here and i'm going to add
poc jsp
and there's a bunch of a's there i
guarantee that was not there a couple
minutes ago when i showed you the site
earlier
what i've done and now the a's that's
not very nefarious really but the
ability to take a jsp and push it to
somebody else's server and have it
actually be there
that's pretty bad
um
let's take a look at
the other side of the script i'm gonna
run the phone side which will inject a
different
jsp out there
if i pull that one up and get a nice
little form
i just ran env
on
a shell basically but in the
environments
that the tomcat server is running in and
i can look at this and shrink it a
little bit here and i can see oh there's
my job at home there's a bunch of
information and oh look at that there's
kubernetes port
that means most likely i am running in a
kubernetes server which means most
likely i'm on a container to your docker
container
and
that's interesting that's the api server
from the point of view of the pod that
i'm in
so
if i wanted to maybe i could start
tickling
the control plane of the kubernetes
cluster i'm in and seeing if there's
anything available to me
in order to do that i'd need cube ctl
or it'd be easier if i had keeps you out
needed but it'd be easier and it doesn't
look like i have that
do i have curl
uh let's just do
curl health i do
so i've got curl at my disposal
now i'm not going to go through in this
demonstration hacking a kubernetes
cluster but i will show you a couple
other things
um oh i'm root so that's nice that means
i can do things like um
oops let me get in the field ls
ltr sc password
and oops not lsltr that's not
interesting this is more interesting
uh etsy password
now i'm in a container
so
these users aren't that interesting to
me but it is i can get at them i can see
them what what can i do what else can i
do can i do this touch etsy food
and see if that works
go to the bottom and sure enough i was
able to create a file in the etc
top level directory on this
container
that's because i'm root and i have write
access everywhere in this container that
means i could go into
the other web app the to-do list and i
can modify it
i could also go change out things in the
jvm itself i have curl
and if i have external network access i
can bring down my own scripts i can
bring my own my own jvm that has maybe
other code baked into it
but honestly most most of the time
what's going to happen now if i'm i'm
root
on a
writable file system container
i'm going to down and i have curl and or
some other tool i can i'm going to
download a script that starts with
crypto mining or something and use up
all the cpu i can on this node so that's
interesting and hopefully you know in a
real server the production intrusion
detection or other alerts are going off
now because i'm doing things that
shouldn't be happening but we don't
really want to just have a reactionary
posture to this how could i as a
developer have proactively avoided this
situation
or dealt with even unknown
vulnerabilities that might be out there
let's take a look at that
so i'm going to go back over here to my
shell kill out of this
now i've already built this image
locally let's imagine i'm i'm the
developer working on this application at
some point and i'm building locally to
check a bug fix i did or whatever and i
built my image so that i can run it
somewhat similar to the way it would run
in production
and
what i can do though is before or during
that process
i can go ahead
and run i'm going to run our scanning
tool there's a lot of different scanning
tools out there
i'm going to run the one that i know the
best which is sneaks i'm gonna do
container
test
and the image name is java goof
tag one
and i'm also gonna feed a
metadata into this command where i say
file is docker file that lets it know
that this is the docker file that built
that image which gives it a little more
information about it so it can kind of
correlate what's in the layers and what
the base images and all that kind of
information so the tool you know
depending what scanner you use the way
this one's working is it's ripping
through all the different layers of the
image looking at all the packages that
are installed looking at the base image
and then it's going to go start querying
the
vulnerability database on the internet
up for the very latest
vulnerability lists and come up with
comparing letting you know what's in
this image and what vulnerabilities
might be there
for the given versions of everything
that's installed
so as this goes we see that there goes
querying the vulnerability database
and there we go so we could go up here
and we could take a look at this list of
all the different things that went wrong
or that could go wrong such as this
there's lib curl has a bunch of
vulnerabilities and it's saying if i
were to upgrade lib curl to that version
we could get you know get past those but
honestly the more interesting thing when
it deals when dealing with containers
from my point of view
is down here at the bottom where we're
saying hey you are on base image 8521 of
tomcat
which we know has 66 critical and 188
high vulnerabilities
635 total
if you simply upgraded to a newer
version of tomcat and this changes every
time i run it because the vulnerability
database is constantly changing um it's
saying if you went to this version you
would drop 222 total vulnerabilities
four high eight
sorry four critical and 18 high
if you were willing to upgrade to a
newer version of tomcat uh family into
the top cat nines you could get even
less and then if you were willing to
actually go to a whole different jvm
this is the amazon coretto jvm i do
believe
um you could actually eliminate all
known vulnerabilities
so at this point even as a junior
developer who doesn't know squat about
tomcat itself and and the image the base
image that's coming from i have some
good information i i know that
you know i've got this many
vulnerabilities and i can have
some quick hit fixes and i can go to my
lead engineer and maybe my appsec person
say hey here's what i'm seeing
which of these makes the most sense uh
to go to and you know it's putting in
the hat of the the architect
well you know we can't really run on
tomcat9 yet because we depend on things
in eight five so that's not really an
option and i am not ready to drink the
the kool-aid of the new coretto jvm so
let's at least move to a newer version
of tomcat but in the 8.5 family let's go
to this one
and we'll take a look at what
vulnerabilities are there and see if we
have mitigating concerns or maybe
they're they're not we're not using that
piece of code that's in them
but but i can we can take an educated
path towards repairing vulnerabilities
and getting past them
i'm not going to go through the trouble
of rebuilding this all and showing you i
just guarantee that if i rebuilt with
that and tried to do the hack i just did
it it won't work because the
vulnerability has been fixed let's talk
a little bit about uh what about
vulnerabilities that we don't know about
that the analysts have not found zero
days things that people are holding on
to for bug bounties whatever
how would i deal with that because a
scanner is not going to know that
well that brings us to a conversation
about
defense in depth this is good for both
known and unknown vulnerabilities these
are practices that make it harder for
bad actors to take advantage of your
systems
they're good all the time
so there's three areas i'm going to
touch on the image the runtime and then
some kubernetes specifics when it comes
to the image number one thing that we
recommend is to minimize your footprint
and you saw me doing that a bit when i
used a multi-stage build prior
that's good because i'm not including
maven or the source code of my
application in that final image but we
could minimize it even further there's
no reason my application should have
curl available it doesn't use it doesn't
need it
so
we should get rid of that
and the best way to get rid of things
like that is to use a smaller base image
first
in the tomcat world there are tags that
have the word slim on the end and this
is true of many base images and these
are built on um in a way that are
they carve it down to just what you need
to run a tomcat app now it may not be
enough for your application in which
case you might have to add a package or
two to it you'll have to manage that but
generally if you're just running a jee
application and you're not doing
anything fancy these slim versions are a
good choice there's even further
slimming you can do by going to say the
google
open source distr
images there's uh
some these have just like the java one
just has a open jdk jvm and nothing else
that's not needed to run that there's no
shell
there's no package manager none of that
and that that's really secure it makes a
little harder to support
if you're not used to using modern tools
if you're wanting to exec in
that's not going to happen because you
don't have a shell to execute right
um you need to understand how layers are
built and the housekeeping around that
so we couldn't just do a run rm curl for
instance to get rid of curl
it would hide it from the container's
file system but a savvy hacker that gets
access to the root file system through
other means whether it be a bind mod or
something
can still find those layers because it's
just hidden it's just marked as deleted
not it's still in the prior layers and
all of those layers exist in the
container runtimes file system
so just understand how layers work and
how they're built and how to optimize
for your running builds
and
build strategies so multi-stage is a
strategy for
doing your builds it's a good one to use
there's other tools you can use though
and other practices you want to make
sure your builds are repeatable so that
every time you pull the same commit out
of source code you get the same image
constructed from it and you can do this
by making sure you pick specific tags on
images you can even put a sha hash into
that image
into that from line and you'll get
you're guaranteed to get that image that
adds some other complexities the people
have blogged about the pros and cons of
that but at least use a specific image
of a um a version like
tomcat 85
68 or 71 or so whatever is better than
eight five because eight five or eight
is a moving target that will go to in
the latest build every time you you pull
it
there's things like docker labels you
should you could use to add metadata to
your images to the image itself that's
not used at runtime but you use it for
fact finding about what's in an image
and there are other tools uh in the java
world there's jib which is a great tool
for building images that doesn't need a
container engine at all to build the
image there's if you're in the red hat
uh environment you've got build uh and
the podman suite of tools um and and
kyberno i'm not typing i'm sorry
and canaco
and uh so many names getting mixed up uh
then we also have uh the secure supply
chain now entire conferences are built
around this topic nowadays but what i
want to
you know kind of hit on is the the
fact that you need to know where your
images come from don't just be deploying
anything and eric smalling building an
image on his laptop that image should
never get to a production server because
you have no idea where it came from what
it was put into it you don't have a
chain of custody you don't know where
it's been and how who's touched it along
the way um
if you're interested go look at the
things like sig store and
the um
work towards uh the software bill of
materials and things like that are are
quite
the topic right now uh nowhere near
enough time to talk about that here when
we get to run time this is where the
real meat of this comes to uh you can
make sure your containers don't run as
root
uh you can use a user line on on the
command line or in kubernetes there's a
setting for that uh you can make sure
that they're running as something else
in fact you can specify in your docker
file the default user is
x
do that running as root is dangerous
even though you're in a container as you
saw i was uid 0 so i could modify any
file in that container
also if somebody heaven forbid were to
bind mount a host volume into that
container i'm uid 0 there too so i can
read and write to host files that are
mounted in
depending on the map how it's done
privileged containers you should never
use unless you're doing something really
low level like uh kubernetes modern
monitoring software or
writing a cni plug-in networking plug-in
um generally this gives you root access
to
devices on the host system and it's just
a terrible thing to give just
most applications
um
linux capabilities these are features of
the linux kernels the system calls that
your process can make to do things that
are a little bit escalated but not quite
root um ping has net cap ads in order to
create icmp packets for instance things
like that um the the the early docker
teams uh and other container engine
teams whittled down
the the a good set um
a small set of these that most
applications should be able to live with
but business applications and stuff that
a lot of people work on day to day don't
need any of them because you're not
doing network low-level stuff and
whatnot so
i would i like to drop all capabilities
and then just add back any that i might
need and there are blogs written all
sorts of of information just google for
it on how to find out what capabilities
you need you can use tools like s trace
or falco to
dig into it next we have the read only
root file system
this uh when you start a container up
the container engine basically takes all
the layers of the image
which are read only
compiles those up creates the virtual
file system that the process sees but
then it adds another read write layer on
top and any modifications of the file
system are done in that read write layer
if you change a file that's in the image
it basically does a copy on write brings
it up to the read write layer and then
makes the modification there any new
files get created there as well
you can however start this is the
default mode you can start the container
without that read write layer
effectively making it a read-only file
system
this is very very good if you can do it
if your application can run in that mode
do it this is makes it immutable which
is one of the twelve factors which we
should all be aiming for in container
land anyway
um
if your app needs to write things to
persist to disk temporarily ephemerally
like a tomcat server to use that example
again has the work directory and some
logs and things uh use the
um a temp fs like uh the kubernetes
empty dirt and mount that path
just for that and it'll get it's it'll
get thrown away when the container gets
destroyed
or mount an external volume and make
sure you set permissions correctly for
you know securely for that but don't um
if you can at all not run in read write
mode that can greatly enhance security
many of the things you saw me starting
to hack at and talk about
if it was read only it would have been
very hard for me to do bitcoin mining
for instance on a read-only file system
would require me to be able to pipeline
curl down my script and pipe it it would
just be harder to do and i'd have no
local cache to store things in and it
just it's a great tool to make it harder
for the hacker
deploying from known sources this kind
of calls back to what i said before
about secure supply chain just make sure
you know where your images come from
don't be deploying from the internet you
should probably have your own registry
uh whether it's a mirror or you know
your own hosted registry
use that
and then finally if you're running on
kubernetes and many of you probably are
there are tools that cover
kubernetes ads that you should take a
look at for instance secrets if you have
credentials or other sensitive
information do not build it into your
image do not include it in a flat file
that you just uh you know bind mount in
don't use config maps though none of
those are secure
secrets can be secure
they by make sure your cluster admin is
encrypting those secrets at rest because
by default they're not you have to do
that if you're rolling your own
kubernetes clusters um but if they are
secrets allow you to have your own
role-based access control applied to
them and it keeps things nice and clean
and separate
speaking role-based access control are
back
use it learn it it can be a little
complicated and hard to understand at
first but learn the ins and outs of it
and you'll be happy that you did
security context this is the
specification for the pods and
containers in kubernetes that implement
a lot of the things i talked about on
the prior slide things like running with
a read-only root file system running as
non you know changing the user you're
running as and enforcing to not be root
things like that are impli are
implemented in kubernetes through the
security context and you should learn
about those and use those
network policies are critical
uh many developers get all worked up
about network policy they think it's
very complicated it's really not it's
just all about setting rules about what
pods can talk to each other and what
can't uh and on what protocol tcp or udp
and what non neo ports and all that i'm
a big fan of the zero trust pattern
which is no pods can talk to any pod no
any other pod
except for what i explicitly put in an
allow list so nobody can talk to anybody
except my pods in the front end
namespace can talk to the business tier
labeled pods on port 8080 tcp
so that traffic specifically is allowed
but other traffic
between front end zero isn't and uh you
should look into that if you do that
make sure you open up um egress traffic
to your dns because if you don't then
you have no service look up and that
crashes everything
pretty much
and finally all of these things i'm
talking about enforce them use a tool
like opa gatekeeper or
kyverno um there's also pod security
policies which is deprecated and going
to be replaced by pod security admission
but that's still in beta as of 123.
if you're watching this one pod security
mission is auto beta you know by all
means use it but use
any kind of these tools to make sure
that deployments that break the rules
the policies that your organization uses
can't be deployed um and just just do it
it's a it's
it simplifies life and if you apply it
across all of your environments then a
developer won't be surprised by the fact
that you know in production i can't
deploy as root what because i haven't
been able to deploy the route on any of
our clusters so it's just a common rule
set that i've used everywhere
so the key takeaways from today's talk
um the feedback loop is critical just
like when ci you know came on the scene
and became a big buzzword
letting me know that the build was
broken as fast as possible that feedback
that fast feedback loop enables
continuous integration well it's the
same thing with security finding out
that i've added security vulnerabilities
or somehow
weakened my security posture of my
application on my own workstation
that's that's critical having that fast
feedback is is
is great because i can fix it now while
it's still fresh in my mind what i've
just did
and it didn't get out and you know cause
impact to other people
secondly the whatever tool you end up
using for scanning and whatnot make sure
that it allows you to be proactive it
gives you good information that allows
you to
attack now rather than just scratch your
head and say well i have no idea what
this means make sure that it's giving
you
good proactive actionable information
and then finally practice defense in
depth there's always going to be new
vulnerabilities that nobody knows about
except that that one hacker that found
it and if you make it harder on the
hacker's life they'll move on to
somebody that's an easier target that's
just how it is
so i want to thank you for uh watching
secure your containers guys thanks
we've reached the end you should now
have a better understanding of devstec
ops and be able to start implementing
some new security tools in your workflow
check out the description for additional
resources
and thanks for watching